this star talk and I'm your personal
astrophysicist Neil deGrasse Tyson and
we're here in a cosmic queries Edition
and I have a new co-host never co-hosted
before ray Ellen ray hello hello in the
house great to see you me I know you cuz
you you basically you're a warm-up guy
yeah I'm a comedian from when we do live
start talking four seasons now four
season season yeah so now we put you in
front of the camera right I can't think
I'm ready can you handle it
think I can't handle it is such a fun
star talk is such a fun show thank you
yeah that's not I'm thanking you for
there's a trickle-down effect starts
with you and it runs through ripples
through the entire well excellent we
it's all labors of love yes sure and I'm
and I'm always delighted you make the
crowd feel at home and comfortable you
only insult them intermittently very
sporadically deserves when they deserve
they deserved influence excellent and
are you active on social media I am uh
at Ray comedy on Instagram and rat ray
comedy on Instagram yeah Instagram Ray
Romano is very upset that I got ray
comedy okay how'd you get that well how
like you're fine with that it up and
then I have twitter is at Ray Ellen Ray
Owen yeah ra y e el L I am I in you got
it okay dude so this is cosmic queries
love cosmic queries and so you got the
questions I got the cold from our social
media yes footprint yeah and bring him I
haven't seen the questions but the topic
solicited is the new space race the new
space for ya not all boring space really
only went to the moon exactly a new
space race where we're trying to get
into that's right the news exciting
updated space race although this first
question it does does pertain to the
moon okay from Ryan Espinoza on Facebook
all right and Ryan wants to know why do
you think we haven't gone back to the
moon and decades and would there be any
good sustainable reason other than
preparing for Mars to have a permanent
research station there
perhaps even to launch spacecraft no no
no there could be reasons but the the
the economics is hard to justify so you
need a reason that overrode the
economics like war or if China says if
we're gonna put military bases on the
moon we're going back to the home back
to the moon right because we then we we
use that as an argument to justify
that's why we went to the moon in the
first place right
Russia was getting our upper hand that
is something nobody talked about
we're Americans right Merc Merc remember
apostrophe mu r RI CA America's we our
our narrative of our history is that we
are pioneers in space okay but let's
look at it the Russians came up with the
rocket equation they see the equation
that tells you how much fuel you need to
put a payload into orbit why does that
matter because you need fuel to carry
the fuel that hasn't burned yet to put
the payload in orbit so for every pound
you want to put into orbit
you need much much more fuel than you'd
otherwise think you'd need and that's
why the Saturn 5 rocket is so tall and
the astronauts and all their payload is
just the upper little sex and all the
rest of that is just controlled bomb Wow
okay so the rocket equation was Russian
so the Russians put up the first
artificial satellite right which was
Sputnik its button yes I think that's
splitting it right here oh okay I got
this in Star City Moscow I mean outside
about it's a very distant suburb of
Moscow where they it's like our Houston
okay except it's really just for space
there are there any Cowboys there so
this is the International Space Station
okay this is Skylab oh cool yeah which
was the there's a Russia that the Apollo
Soyuz project we use the Skylab as a
space station so that's smaller than the
International right I have no idea what
this is it looks like a flying saucer
could have been some prototype thing
that the Russians did design here this
is some large satellite satellite
we keep going and this make in the
tiniest of the dolls look at that that's
a very very clever how this translates
to radio I just disassembled one of
these dogs what do they call that the
Russian dolls yeah the Russian dog the
nesting Russian dolls but there's a
there's a I was thinking a Faberge egg
it's not a fabrication no no
so the littlest aren't one in there
normally they have like heads of state
or right the Pope's or prime ministers
or czars these are spaceships and you
crack that one open it'll be a little
bottle of vodka crack that open be a
little piece of potato so Sputnik they
had the first non-human animal in space
who's that chimp no non-human animals at
all was it really yes what kind of a dog
Laika so mutt I don't I don't know if
it's a mutt but I think it was kind of
like a mud they think it was a stray dog
from from Moscow how would you feel
you're a stray dog just running into the
streets of Moscow next thing you know
you're up in orbit well they had no
plans to bring it back alive maybe you
have second thoughts however I'm
thinking myself if I were a dog I could
be a stray dog and die in the streets of
Moscow in the winter or be the most
famous dog since Lassie sure and die in
space that's yeah that's not a bad
option or eat or how about just being
adopted by a family with a yard so
there's some bitterness about the fact
that there's no plans to bring it back
alive and who's a Russian mutt
yeah I think it's most of some kind of
breed but I don't think was a I don't
remember it being a purebred anyway they
had so throughout the rough and the
first human in space okay and that was
who the first human ever yes Yuri
Gagarin yes it was your gig in it he
said yes you have a good you save
yourself on that one have to quickly it
meant I knew it was very silly and Brian
died that was that was very and so they
also had the first it was a lot of first
and then we landed on the moon first
right then we say we win and when
obviously we walked on the moon first
yeah
just saying we landed on the moon first
night and we say we win the race right
when almost every other important
achievement in space was achieved by the
Russians and the reality of that
progression of achievements is what
spooked us because they were
accomplishing things faster and better
than we were and so then we leap frogged
it and then we went to the moon so that
that's all I'm saying
so but going back to what Ryan and I
forgot what I forgot the question but
why isn't the moon useful to launch
spacecraft ok so here's a problem if
you're going to leave earth to go to the
moon - then go to Mars just go straight
to Mars right ok
all right you're good any fuel to land
on the moon because you have to slow
down fuel is not just to go fast once
you're going fast how are you gonna slow
down in our atmosphere you can use
aerobraking which is why we have heat
shields because all you need heat
shields otherwise you'll burn up glad
you glad you're going through the
atmosphere I don't need fuel to do it
right using the friction and shockwaves
between the craft and the air to slow it
down so that I don't need to use retro
rockets to slow down you go to the moon
you need retro rockets to slow yourself
- you have to carry fuel that you're not
using it so no plate the moon would not
be a place to organize - then go to Mars
you want to organize organize in zero-g
in a in a lagrangian point through these
points where gravity balances ok between
the moon and the earth and the planets
we just put stuff there it just stays
you can make really big ships and then
you leave from zero gravity and now
you're not trying to climb out of what
we call a gravitational well which is
all the exhaust that's coming out of our
rockets needs to do that's interesting
that'll ever become a reality
possibly but unless there's a war driver
there's got to be an economic driver in
otherwise I don't see it happening ever
at all right so I wrote a whole book on
this that I wanted to call failure to
launch the dreams and delusions of space
enthusiasts and then publish doesn't
know we can't have a the word failure in
a title that's just bad but I'd loved
the title they said by the way isn't
there a movie with that time yes except
I'm using the title literally failure to
launch that one was figurative about
failure failing to leave home and get
married so why just call it a successes
and unsuccessful in the world of
launching unsuccess is so I settled on
the title space chronicles facing the
ultimate frontier half of that book is
on why we didn't continue to go to Mars
my takeaway from this is that you've
written so many books you can't remember
the names of them that is remark I
didn't so I'm sorry I don't know yeah I
did that's a maze I didn't know it came
out that way no that was nothing awesome
that was not as pretty impressive
actually I give you my one impressive
book story yeah my first time I ever met
Carl Sagan I was 17 I'm in his office
I'm sitting across his desk and he's I
give you a gift
he reaches behind does not even look
grabs a book from the shelf and it's his
book and he signs it to me
Wow I said that is badass everything you
don't even whatever you touch it's gonna
be one of your bookcase full of sake and
then it was like some years later you
know after my sixth book or something I
had them lined up behind me and a kid
comes in and I just reached back and I
say damn I'm like that's what I'm doing
did you reach back and grab one Hagen's
books no fifteen fifteen yeah but a four
or five of them are co-authored because
you can't know everything or anything
you're right about but some of them are
more proud of than others but there's
it's an opus of my effort to communicate
the universe to the public that's
amazing yeah that's my sister Abbie just
wrote her second book called duped and
it's I see firsthand up-close how
difficult it is to write a book oh yeah
that many that's incredible oh yeah no
it's a hole it's a it's the chapter of
your life it's a it's a piece of you in
the book right and when you're done you
just got to regrow the organs that you
expend you know regrow your your energy
refill your fuel tanks regain energy
re-establish your existence as an entity
because you're putting so much of
yourself in the book it's a joy this is
why after every episode of star talk
when Chuck nice and I say to Neil hey
you want to go out maybe why no I gotta
go home I things to do like
write another book simulator number the
amount of interstitial time most people
spend doing nothing is extraordinary
yeah I'm writing yeah that's exactly
right it's great great use of time yeah
Noel spent some time writing Matt hare
field all right so what do you have next
question why are we framing this as a
race is there an end goal that one
country could achieve first realism this
was a thoughtful question oh man 30
seconds to writing it's you know race
implies there's a big start point and an
end point right and the race to the moon
that we won but we didn't win the race
to space itself Russia won that race so
many people say Mars is the next obvious
choice you're not gonna go to Venus it's
hotter than a pizza oven on Venus right
by the way so Mars would be the next
obvious target but I have a contrarian
view here I don't call cut country and I
have a unorthodox view here I want to
build the capacity to explore without
reference to where you're going so you
have a warehouse of rockets and you so
what do you want to do in space ray I'm
gonna let's play baseball you want to
play baseball so play baseball on the
moon loved it okay so and you should
know that the restaurants on the moon
they have no atmosphere so so you wanna
play baseball so you might want to do
that on the moon so you go what Rockets
do you need how many people you to take
with you that's this vessel with this
many rockets and you need to last this
long so you need this food supply and
oxygen the sort of thing and then that's
your then you go to the moon and have
fun there's scientists that might want
to study the possibility of life on Mars
in a pre if some other Genesis on Mars
so they'll bring equipment with them and
they want to go that maybe they want
robots
maybe they'll stay in orbit and control
robots
down on the surface so what I want is
everybody's creativity to be empowered
by our capacity to explore space and
that way no one is saying where the
destination is so in that sense it's
actually not a race it's let's all go
play in our backyard and that backyard
is the solar system right and well put
its it uh it's amazing to me I always
thought it's just so interesting how
everything has to be turned into sort of
framed as a competition well it's it's
we're human and particularly you know
there are people who rise to higher
heights when they compete well when I
first started watching the Olympics I
thought to myself why is it that you can
set a world record in the Olympics why
don't you set the world record a week
ago right it's you you're the same
person how different are you this week
than last week is that yes or than a
month ago
right why did you send it work because
the competition the moment the urge the
that the pageantry all comes together
and creates a will a a force almost
another force of nature operating on
your ambitions but it also creates a
sense of pressure that maybe someone can
maybe someone could run run the fastest
time ever uh if he didn't feel as
pressure for example to some people who
can only sing in the shower they can't
sing on stage they're great in the
shower what if something I can see I
seem really good in the shower and I
could sing on stage but no one would
want me to remake of Jesus yeah she's
quite superstars my favorite musical and
and I saw it in 1971 oh yeah with an
original cast including Ben Vereen as as
Judas I saw when you were 2 years old
yes but why did you oh yeah so so I
don't have a voice that I that's good I
don't have a good singing voice other
than I just sing in the shower right but
there's some people who sound incredible
in the shower and wouldn't be good in
front of a live audience so I'm sure
there's people that participate in the
Olympics who maybe aren't maybe they
could have broken the world record just
sort of on their own time like on a
random Sunday they get out
we need an Olympics with no cameras and
no audience okay no fanfare the home
Olympics the whole no impish yeah I will
see we'll see how that one count at one
place yeah that goes
so yeah competition drives it so does
the urge to gain wealth and power right
so that's driven all the greatest
projects that humans have ever done in
the history of civilization greatest in
terms of what what fraction of a
society's intellectual physical and
financial capital was invested in it so
when that's high generally its praise of
royalty gods and royalty it's economics
or it's war and today you don't have
praise of royalty triggering expensive
projects the way we once did right in
civilization so that we basically leaves
war and money more money
I wish that were not true I'm just
simply reporting yeah what has driven
and motivated people yeah in the past
and so yes competition to be the first
two to get the economic return or to get
the high ground if there's a military
motive to it the Cheney effect yeah
definitely
all right next question next up all
right next question is from Pedro Sam
made yo on Facebook page or ass are
there any international ethics or rules
for Space Exploration let's suppose for
example that Changi 4 had a problem when
landing and this is it this is the
Chinese mission that landed on the
backside of the moon yes yes okay yes
the back side are dark sides the same
thing no no two different things
in spite of the 1973 album by Pink Floyd
yes the dark side there's no dark side
and all sides of the Moon received light
uh yeah damn the moon lasts a month
oh no kidding yeah yeah so there's a far
side of the Moon that's why I said the
back side I got you okay I get the under
not the underside it's not there's not a
place where the Sun don't shine okay so
okay so when checking for yeah if it had
a problem on landing and the potato
seeds and silkworms were spread over
lunar soil were they to be punished
somehow for contaminating lunar soil
with terrestrial life
yeah so everything so they're three
things here in 1967 there's something
called the International Space Treaty
it's a much longer title but that's you
want to shorten it the International
Space Treaty okay it's signed by one
hundred more than hundred countries and
it's a code of conduct for space very
kumbaya they saw them that the Cold War
was getting hotter and space was
becoming a contested regime again of
international politics and the UN said
we got to do something about this so in
it it says if you're in trouble
even if we're enemies on the ground I
got to help you I will bring you food or
help me you know it's this kind of it's
a it's very you're the forward-looking
and unifying yeah that's beautiful mine
my cynical skepticism is if you can
actually pull that off in space why did
you pull that off down here right but
wait wait what why space different right
you're humans and we're human all right
we kill each other from limited
resources we kill each other because
your skin color is different because you
worship a different God because you live
on a different side of the line in the
sand why do we think and if you can't
accomplish it up there let's do that
here let that be evidence that you could
do it in space that that's my cynical
side of it but so we have that but
you're right I mean you are right I did
say we don't allow greed on rockets in
addition NASA has a branch of itself
called planetary protection office and
this protects contamination in
destination places of earth life okay
and it protects earth life from what
could be a contaminant brought back from
space and their regulations about that
and what what level contamination and
sterilization is allowed for different
kinds of objects so Europa that one has
the highest chance of their having life
so you want the most sterile objects
going there to minimize the risk of
contamination the moon itself is kind of
sterile we're not worried about
contamination
life that's there because it's got no
atmosphere the ultraviolet light which
is hostile to life the molecules of life
just breaks apart the molecules and so
there's asteroids hitting all the time
so we're not worried that if you go to
the moon and sneeze you're going to
contaminate a future experiment that
we're conducting so so there's there's a
lot written on it but no nobody gets
punished there's you you look bad on the
international stage but there's no
digital punishment so it's no go back
three spaces so you're saying so so
China will not be penalized for bringing
50 children on the on that mission so
they could make sneakers on the moon -
so how did how did seeds breaking open -
defective free that'd be very costly
very costly and child labor historically
had been through there's no child on the
moon yeah so that's another question
yeah what what what is a crime in a
place that's not within a municipality
correct right yeah right
and I don't get me started like even
alien more intelligence in you lands and
you kill it is that murder right there's
the whole thing right a whole legal
frontier here well yeah well you could
argue I mean he he he he reached for his
uh he it's a mercy to me to me yeah I
know I made it male you're right you
totally made it a male that's terrible
the alien reach its reach for some days
ER that's a 1964 yeah so there's a whole
frontier there and that's a great
question but no there's no penalties the
other than maybe we won't invite you on
our next mission that's probably penalty
enough that's a death right now we gotta
take a break
start talk cosmic queries the next space
race edition
back cosmic queries this is the next
space race edition and I have a newbie
as my co-host ray ellen ray he's just a
newbie as my co-host but he's been in
the comedy scene forever
and in fact you have your own comedy
like Ray's comedy club I have in in on
the island of Aruba that's a crazy news
come when you flying us all down you are
to Startalk that Bruin I'm heading down
tomorrow and I expect everybody to be
joining me monkey first in Aruba you
know very cool we got a well maybe we're
gonna cruise and that's a port of call
you can set sure okay I love it all
right love it I'm bringing up onstage if
you come down yeah so bring me some
questions okay
ah this is cosmic queries cosmic queries
is from Woody from Adelaide Australia
what is the goal line for scoring in the
new space race last time it was boots on
the moon on that a station on Mars would
be cool yeah so that's a great question
I can't speak for everyone but I can
definitely list certain things that have
not been accomplished yet okay so if you
go to the moon and set up a colony
mm-hmm
whether it's a permanent colony or a
colony or a place that you visit
seasonally you want to be able to use
local resources to make stuff and in
NASA abbreviation lingo it's is are you
in situation so it's better discussed
with regard to Mars you go to Mars are
you bringing all the water with you that
you'll ever need no that's kind of
stupid if you're driving to Los Angeles
you don't bring all the water you need
you're gonna stop places yeah and pick
up some mortars and you refuel your tank
you're not gonna go with one fuel tank
yeah it's got to be bigger because you
got to make it to Los Angeles no you
they're filling stations along the way
so one goal is that space becomes space
itself becomes a self-supporting
commodity if you will so you don't need
a huge
it needs a half-size rocket a refuel
halfway there you don't need all the
water you're ever gonna drink get to
Mars sift the water out from beneath the
soil beneath the the the surface and
melt that and now you have water oh by
the way water also serves as rocket fuel
build the factory separate the two
molecules the two atoms what are they a
mortar
what's the molecular form of water
hydrogen and and thank you h2o question
I think you're trying to trick me no
question guy no the trickster no I ask
very simple question yeah well thank
goodness okay so h2o if you separate
those two atoms and put them in separate
liquefied tanks so liquid liquefied
hydrogen liquefied very cold they cool
it down it liquefies and then have a
nozzle that connects them it's a highly
exothermic reaction vectors endothermic
means the reaction absorbs energy around
it yeah exothermic means it releases
energy you bring hydrogen together it's
rocket fuel so you can have water there
that you can drink water that can serve
as a as rocket fuel and so then you
don't have to bring it okay well how
about food well we mark Watney solve
that one group potatoes so you grow
something first figure that out it
literally gonna be greenhouses this sort
of thing so one of the goal lines or
high bars for us is in situ resource
utilization and now that we have 3d
printers there's something breaks I need
a nut a bolt of fan blade print it send
in the cat you get the kid load up the
cab from Earth the computer-assisted
design load it from Earth because I'm
not gonna design it on Mars on I don't
have that talent right get somebody
design it oh here's that new parts you
need just bring the designer with you no
not it wouldn't have to you would if you
just bring the Machine yeah there's a
time delay of like 20 minutes but that's
fine what about long distance energy
transfer is that is that something that
we're sort of you mean oh well so no I
Rockets we're still using chemical fuels
in a rocket well you know we need warp
drives
warp drive we need phasers and what
phasers and warp drives and we don't
have flying cars yet but we need the
warp drive like real soon then you could
cross the galaxy during the TV
commercial otherwise you know you're
dead the time it takes to travel star to
star isn't commensurate with the life
expectancy of human physiology is that
right yeah so going the fastest we've
ever gone sent anything if I aim for
Alpha Centauri the nearest star to the
Sun ask me how long it takes how does it
take I mean depending there's a tailwind
with the tailwind fifty thousand years
Wow I see I find that it's sad I find it
depressing it said so depressed so
you're not going to alpha century
I'm not going to Queen and then you say
what do you want a generation ship are
you gonna commit future generations to
live out their entire lives just to make
more babies on a ship so that's some
generation a thousand generations down
lands
you know enters the the space of a the
sector where you have the nearest star
this is not sensible right it's really
not practical yeah so we need warp drive
I got people I got men huh okay how
about this is nice uh this is from uma
Claire on Instagram she said hi my name
is Uma Claire my family and I always
listen to you on our way to school I
certainly can't wait to hear this
episode of all the countries likely to
be involved in the new space race which
is the closest to bringing people to
Mars calculations and testing wise oh
ooh
nobody is close to doing that now but
when China says they want to do
something in space or technologically
they just do it hmm
because they have that power over their
resources in ways that democracies don't
right we have to kind of all agree the
population has to agree not so in China
China just decides as a country this is
our next we're doing it we're doing
doing it we're doing it right so all I
have to do is say we're gonna put a tie
Connaught on Mars
or orbit Mars and then they'll just do
it in the timeframe established for it
so I have no doubt that that resolve is
real even though it's not a stated goal
at this moment of course Elon Musk what
is a stated goal he wants to put people
on Mars but there's no business case for
that right you could do it as a one-off
you can get together with Jeff Bezos and
get them multi-billionaires so let's
just put it put somebody on Mars right
but if you're an investor in that
company and you say well like it's a
short meeting it's so what are you gonna
do Elon I'm gonna put humans on Mars how
much does it cost
trillion dollars I don't know probably
more is it dangerous yes well people die
probably what's my return on investment
nothing
that's a five-minute meeting I say this
all the time that's a five-minute
meeting so unless we discover oil on
Mars right diamonds but China can do it
for no other reason just but that they
want to do it right because then if
you're not a completely free society
then you just decide to do it like the
Pharaoh said make me the biggest peer
the biggest tombstone ever and so they
make pyramids when they just do it man
we should spread a rumor that there is
oil on my no no it's spread a rumor that
China wants to build military bases on
Mars I just have to leak a fake memo
right and and have the CIA discover it
fake it just do it and then well then
we're going to Mars that's a that's a
that's a great premise removed for a
movie I love it oh yeah that's the next
Will Smith movie yeah so here's a
scenario that I can imagine China builds
up their interest in Mars and they want
to send people even if they want to do
it peacefully forget war won't do it
people but we still will get a little
bit spooked by that all right we'll
react
yeah we'll say we're going to Mars right
Oh NASA doesn't have a spaceship to do
so we have one that's kind of works but
does anyone else have a spaceship and
Elon raises his hand I got one right
here in the warehouse right so then
right here right here next to the pool
and I was blue so we end up using an
Elon spaceship that he diligently built
research designed and built and that's
good but that's not a LAN landing on
Mars
that's the American taxpayer
that's the difference right so there's
no longer private time it's not a
business model magnet searcher we're
doing it yeah there it is
Thanks uma all right we gotta take a
break when we come back more of the next
space race on Startalk cosmic queries
edition we're back on Startalk cosmic
queries edition the next space race is
the subject and I got ray Ellen with me
hello Naomi all right ray you have a
teep TV show now on Comedy Central yes
that's very cool yeah it's very cuz you
all like calm and cool here in my office
but you're badass outside of a very
humble dude well this week at the Comedy
Cellar
it's on Comedy Central Friday nights we
just wrapped season one nice season two
should be starting up probably this week
so it's like like John Oliver this week
tonight yeah a review of the it's a
weekly topical stand-up show we have
about 20 different comics come on every
episode every episode yeah every episode
we have a great nice nice I'll check it
how does our listener find you
I'll go to comedycentral.com/tosh.o
sewed it's that's been archived nice
alright good see I thought we were your
only gig and now I'm happy and sad you
are my favorite gig Comedy Central's not
blasting me into space I don't know if
you will but what questions you got
alright here we go this is from Alma
toss star from Instagram mm-hmm when
will the space for start cleaning up
space or is there another program that's
already working on space cleaning sigh
you know step-daughter ego uh readings
from Porter's space force so a lot to
talk about space force yeah Trump said
he wants to space we sure that's what
let me just say unequivocally yeah that
just because Trump mentioned it does not
mean it's a crazy idea just for the for
the Trump naysayers out there sure I
just want just just right the mom they
hear that word Trump they immediately
just yeah they can't listen to anything
else a competitor yeah space force is he
is practical reasonable
I don't care really but I can tell you
the the benefits of it it's will focus
attention that is already allocated to
space within the Air Force the Air Force
has United States Space Command the Air
Force has been thinking about space ever
since we've had access to space you know
who else is thinking about space the CIA
and the reconnaissance agents other
reconnaissance agencies because space is
the high ground so when you think of
space force and you want to think of
space war the urge is Star Wars with
lasers and weapons and phasers you need
the photon torpedoes but but it turns
out it's very impractical to attack
earth targets from space right because
you're moving 18,000 miles an hour in
orbit and that's just really fast
to then aim and do something on earth
it's just when we can send an
intercontinental ballistic missile and
hit a target any place on earth within
45 minutes to say oh we got to wait
until the satellite is in position so no
no you just through so we already know
how to kill each other
from surface based weaponry we already
know that so space is not in improving
that okay
quote improving that so what sort of
space is a place for reconnaissance and
by the way the Air Force no one
questions why do we have an Air Force
they used to be a branch of the army it
was the Army Air Force throughout the
whole Second World War but but the
notion of space for us to be sort of oh
yeah I got you the engineer that fixes
the tank is that the same engineer that
fixes the airfoil on an airplane no no
the the grunt on the ground is carrying
the weapon is that the same soldier
training as the pilot of the jet fighter
no so you be branching off air force
from the army and no one is really
questioning that the value of that so to
branch off space force from the Air
Force
why are you gonna have an issue with
that that's and by the way if you're
gonna do that let's add
let's add priorities to whatever it is
they were doing before and one of them
would be let's clean up space right
space debris space litter litter oh um I
think that's why we haven't been visited
by aliens too many balloons okay no no
they just looked at it said you guys are
nasty slob just slob dirty filthy dirty
filthy
so NASA tracks space debris so that when
they launched the next thing that'll
slam into it right all right the space
station has limited maneuverability
power in case something is headed its
way so yeah that another one what I want
them to do is deflect the asteroids yes
I don't wanna be like the dinosaurs
going extinct because we have a space
program they asked any dinosaurs didn't
so I didn't tell you that baseboard yeah
the front man in red and what see the
the badass one was Rodin um was yeah the
supersonic yeah pterodactyl sure
supersonic yeah definitely so so what am
I saying so yeah you'd want
I think you'd want to add to their
portfolio but wouldn't space for sort of
be if it because it's this all of space
outer space
wouldn't that need to be an
international organization you know
that's a really good that's that's good
that's like saying the air molecules
above this country belong to the United
States correct that's kind of you know
it's insane they are moved it's insane
yeah right so insane you you can say you
I don't want you over this country but
to declare ownership of air when air
travels around the world
yeah it's that kind of thing yeah I own
space no you know no you can't own space
I like to dispute air rights on top of
my apartment
so yeah ownership is a thing so I think
what the any discussion about ownership
is about who owns the moon who owns an
asteroid you go to an asteroid to mine
its natural resources do you own it or
does everyone it Finders Keepers man
now but it's a great point I mean that's
like saying do we own them when we put a
flag on the moon the moon as it moves us
it's you at us light yeah we didn't put
the UN flag on the moon we put the US v
so it's it's it's it's us light it's the
United States it's ours
it's our you know I'm saying little
island by the way you cannot see the
flag the flag that we that that the Neil
Armstrong and Buzz Aldrin planted on the
moon you cannot see that with any the
Hubble telescope wouldn't can't cap it's
too small to resolve with with
ground-based telescopes or the size of
telescopes that are in orbit but you can
see the flag from satellites that orbit
the moon image you can see that the
rover tracks it's kind of cool oh that's
cool yeah that's awesome
you know they got wrong in what movie
was that was it interstellar no no
transformers I think was one of the
Transformers movies they show one of
their craft passing by the moon and you
see the the landing spot for the Apollo
astronauts but it still has the it still
has the lemon oh that right yeah because
that that departed from it he just have
the spidery legs around behind yeah so
they left the whole thing cuz you
wouldn't recognize it as anything if
it's just a platform so did you retreat
that at some point not it's a little
obscure we have too many Game of Thrones
tweets together you know yeah it just
looks so naked to just have the base in
these four legs so they left the whole
module there that the astronauts
occupied so it looks like a landing spot
is this sort of is it understood that if
China were to land right where we had
landed the US Atlanta that they're not
supposed to you know supposed to tamper
with any of the flag the when has the
history of human conduct fulfilled
anything that was supposed to be
anything yeah yeah if they went up in
and and like broke the flag yeah
technical foul 15-yard penalty that so
yeah I mean that would be I'd wanted to
say there was an act of war I would say
it would be a profound act of disrespect
yeah
and there would probably be
repercussions it would certainly with
this administration yeah disrespect yeah
especially since to be a moon tariff
especially since even though we planted
an American flag Neil Armstrong laid a
plaque that said we come in peace for
all mankind
didn't say we come for America right for
Americans right and I don't know any
active exploration
we're upon planting a flag the next
words were uttered were we come in peace
for everyone all of humanity right the
history that exercise especially
Europeans leaving Europe is I put a flag
here now we own it right and we have
warships to back up that statement right
no matter who you find living there so
it was a fundamentally different act and
so we'll see what the future of this is
I don't know yeah Alexis wall drill of
Instagram Alexis from Hong Kong here
when do you think will start sending
world leaders into space and if we could
do that now who would you send Oh
didn't I did I do this on another
episode I can't do it too often but I'm
gonna do it again now okay are you ready
for this right you're not ready are you
ready I'm ready
I am oh are you ready for this I don't
hold on a second
I'm ready you're feeling it okay you're
ready
which world leaders should we send into
space okay so first we should send all
the flat-earthers into space okay okay I
think I think they wanted that anyway so
Kerry you every not a world leader but
he can go yeah no just so they can see
they can orbit the earth and see that
earth is a sphere okay and then you
bring him back and say you're happy now
Oh for education educator I'm an
educator do that's true yeah you
demonstrate yeah the roundness of earth
okay next you send all world leaders
okay it'll be like a
people-mover van okay no if we have to
be bigger than how many worldly hundreds
of world leaders hundred hundreds okay
you ready thousands if you can't be on
this is a quote exactly yeah but if
leaders of established nations it's a
hundred and something how many countries
are there is one seventy four hundred
yeah it's between one and two hundred
entries yeah we got our crack team
researching this net how much your one
ninety five so 200 countries so two
hundred world leaders okay okay here we
go do they get a plus-one okay four
hundred world leaders I'm gonna read a
quote from Edgar Mitchell okay
Apollo three Powell fourteen fourteen
that's right Apollo one through six were
scrapped after we lost the three Apollo
one astronomic stop our was Apollo seven
it's that question again okay so here we
go you develop an instant global
consciousness a people orientation and
intense dissatisfaction with the state
of the world and a compulsion to do
something about it from out there on the
moon international politics looks so
petty you want to grab a politician by
the scruff of the neck and drag them a
quarter million miles out and say look
at that you son of a [ __ ] that's great
that's juicy juicy just give a cosmic
perspective reality check to every
politician and then bring them back down
to earth I think they'll be changed yeah
that's what the universe can do to you
when you see earth as only nature can
present it to you with oceans and land
and clouds no color coded national
boundaries no none of the usual
trappings of who owns what part of what
section of the world it's just a planet
our life-giving planet you can't make
peace on that planet with all human
beings
I you don't deserve the power that
science has given you to serve as a
shepherd of our future survival on this
planet you don't deserve it you should
just go somewhere else put people in
power who understand what earth is what
it means to us and all the other life on
Earth and what steps they need to take
to cherish this place that we have
borrowed from our descendants that would
be a great unifying experience I think
if you could do that if you could send
those 200 people up up together yeah I
really have to really think it would
after you set up the flat earthers yeah
I actually like to become a flat earther
the first true that's a nice trip it's
far better than getting you a freebie to
Cape Cod so ray we got a rap that we got
out we got a call Chris here uh well I
just thought before we go I just want
everyone to know I came across Neil's
book accessory to war in my office so
the blouse that's how I came across it I
was snooping around his office and an in
between all the bobbleheads of him and
and the the the Campbell's soup the Star
Wars Campbell's Soup said he has up
there on the shelves oh that's what this
one is is is primordial soup oh it's
just soup straight here primordial soup
on that shelf over there you have a Star
Wars but this is accessory to Ward's the
unspoken alliance between astrophysics
and the military you this is a book you
a few months ago that came out yeah last
September a co-authored with office Lang
a major it's like 500 pages so my book
before that was astrophysics four people
in a hurry yes this is astrophysics for
people not an honor yes make that clear
yeah the other book I read on a subway
ride this one's gonna take me a subway
right before stops it's been taken again
you late another labor of love it's the
history because science is not untouched
by war and the funding for it that
enable it that empower it and that feed
it and so this is just a candid review
an assessment of what that relationship
has been between the history of
astrophysics
and wore it so I'm excited to try to
tackle this you are the most prolific
non comedian I've ever met like that
some economics I know who just write
endlessly oh yeah and I'm all in on
cough this is unbelievable 15 books and
there's a new word for being a non comic
is called a non comic million really we
got to go
great thanks for doing it thanks man a
lot of fun okay we're gonna get back
again love it and the invitation to
Aruba stands ah a wide open all right
you've been listening to possibly even
watching this space race episode of star
talk and I've been your host Neil
deGrasse Tyson and as always I bid you
[Music]